all right I want to start today with yet
another reminder based on a new study
that gun violence is dramatically worse
in red States one of the big narratives
that is going to play a significant role
in the 2024 election is that a violent
crime and murder and guns and
Republicans pointing to so-called
Democrat cities and suggesting that
Urban progressives I guess are
responsible for violence and gun
violence and crime this is very much not
true there's a really good piece in
Politico magazine called gun violence is
actually worse in red States it's not
even close and it looks at this issue in
a number of different ways and one of
the findings of the study
is that gun deaths are far less common
in the New York City area than in the
U.S overall debunking one of the very
often repeated claims from the right
that New York City is some kind of
dangerous hellhole and the article
explains that if you grew up in the coal
mining region of eastern Pennsylvania
your chance of dying of a gunshot is
about half if you grew up in the coal
fields of West Virginia similar regions
relatively Rural and relatively
conservative but you have stricter gun
laws in blue Pennsylvania than in Red
West Virginia and you're much less
likely to die of a gunshot and as you
read the article whether you divide the
country up regionally or state to state
you find that historically and presently
blue areas are significantly safer when
it comes to gun violence it's beyond the
scope of this segment to go through the
entire piece with you but it divides the
country up into all sorts of different
areas and looks at this in so many
different ways the Deep South has some
of the highest rates of gun death among
major regions and it's one of the most
conservative parts of the country great
Appalachia has the highest rate of gun
suicides among major regions and that is
a right-wing area and you go on and on
and you find that this is a quite
frankly uh an undeniable reality now one
of the important things to remember
about why this isn't going to convince
the deniers and we'll link to this in
the description to the YouTube video and
I encourage you to look at it and check
it out and you know maybe it will change
some minds but one of the problems with
this issue and I've explained this
before is that number one violence and
crime are genuinely really complicated
issues that can relate to culture but
also economics gun laws access to mental
health services so many different things
this doesn't mean we ignore any one
aspect or focus on only one aspect it
just means it's complicated but the
trend line is that gun violence is much
worse in red States
one of the things that will often happen
is if you say oh the red states are
where the problem is you'll have some
right Wingers come in and say no but if
you look at the red states where the
real problem is is in the blue cities
and of course by sheer numbers it can
sometimes be the case that it is worse
in in cities but when you look at rates
that account for population density it
stops being the case but then if you say
well it's a blue City but all the
violence is in the areas represented by
the conservative City councilors or
whatever the case may be you can zoom in
or out strategically
in order to get the outcome that you
want and that can also make this a
difficult conversation to have but the
big story which is conservatives blaming
blue Democrat cities and urban gun
violence on gangs and Welfare queens and
pretending that this isn't an issue in
Rural and conservative West Virginia or
the right wing deep south or whatever
the case may be is simply not true one
other thing the right loves to talk
about you know Chicago and Baltimore as
these crime-ridden hell holes the truth
is that even within cities that have gun
violence problems the gun violence is
overwhelmingly concentrated in a few
areas most of Chicago most of New York
City most of Baltimore does not actually
have these issues this is aside from
whether
the issues relate to a particular
politics or how it relates to the state
or whatever the case may be even Within
These so-called dangerous cities the
violence is overwhelmingly only in
certain areas and this makes it a really
difficult issue to tease out one
particular cause what we know when it
comes to solving the problem
is that before even you know just on
principled so many on the American right
don't even want to consider the fact
that guns guns and gun availability may
have something to do with it and as I've
said before
let's talk about mental health let's
talk about culture let's talk about
poverty let's talk about education let's
talk about all those things but we can't
exclude guns from the gun problem guns
have to be part of that discussion and
um check out the Politico magazine piece
it's it's very very good one of our
sponsors is short form short form makes
the world's best guides to non-fiction
books and not only does short form
Summarize each non-fiction book itself
into key points that you can cover in
just a few minutes they have all sorts
of interactive exercises to help you
apply the ideas to what you've read to
retain more the guide to each book also
includes intellectual insights comparing
and contrasting the book to other
prominent books about the same topic so
that you can contextualize the book and
understand the controversies and the
disagreements they also have books
across every non-fiction genre from
economics and politics to science and
health I was recently checking out James
clear's Atomic habits on one short form
of course they have the guide but they
also have highlights they also include
other similar books about habits and
developing a routine with differences
and similarities super super useful and
a lot more than just a summary of the
book there are new guides and articles
released every week and short form is
giving my audience a free trial plus 25
off a subscription which is a 50 value
so for the price of a book per month you
get access to thousands go to
shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below